ROGER MARTINEZ: Hi, Roger
here from Google Cloud.
And in this video,
we'll have a look
at how Contact Center AI can
help the financial services
industry by transforming
your customer service.
Various external events,
like natural disasters,
can have serious impacts
on financial institutions.
Such events can create
an influx of requests
from customers looking for
information and support.
But limited human resources,
unprecedented network
infrastructure loads,
and restrictions
on travel and
working from offices
can hinder financial services
organization's ability
to deliver critical
services to their customers
and communities.
This can put a huge strain
on a number of infrastructure
and core business systems.
One area that bears
the most strain
is where customers
directly interface
of your business, things like
call centers and customer
support lines can see
unprecedented volume increases.
And if you're not set
up to handle the scale,
your customers could suffer.
For example long wait times
on hold or an email query
going too long before
being responded to,
can lead to unhappy
customers, and potentially
long live conversations
that drive up
costs for call centers.
The simplest solution is to
increase your service forces
to respond to demand.
But that's not always
as easy as it sounds.
The costs of hiring and
training new support workers
can have a significant impact
on your operational efficiency
and your profitability.
The bottom line is, that during
times of high volume customer
needs, your company
will have to find
the balance between offering
exceptional customer
service and personalized
intuitive customer care,
while increasing
operational efficiency.
Thankfully, Google Cloud
Contact Center AI, CCAI,
is here to help.
CCAI uses artificial
intelligence
to converse naturally
with customers,
and expertly assess human
agents on more complex cases.
CCAI's conversational core
powers three key features.
Virtual Agent gives
customers 24/7 access
to immediate
conversational self-service
with seamless hand-offs to human
agents for more complex issues.
Agent Assist
empowers human agents
with continued support
during their calls
by identifying intent
and providing real time,
step by step assistance.
Insights uses natural
language processing
to identify call drivers
and sentiment that helps.
Contact Center managers learn
about customer interactions
to improve call outcomes.
Let's see how
Contact Center AI is
helping transform the
financial services industry.
[RINGTONE]
VIRTUAL AGENT: Hi, Prisha,
thanks for calling our bank.
How can I help?
PRISHA: Hi, I'd
like to pay my bill.
VIRTUAL AGENT: Great.
Can you please
verify your address?
PRISHA: 15 State Street.
Oh, and how much is it?
ROGER MARTINEZ:
Virtual Agent provides
immediate conversational
support, with customers
directing the flow.
VIRTUAL AGENT: You owe $150.
Do you want to pay with
the account ending in 1337?
PRISHA: Yes, please.
VIRTUAL AGENT: Done.
I've sent an email confirmation.
Is there anything else?
ROGER MARTINEZ:
Virtual agent can
take care of basic
fulfillment on the spot.
PRISHA: Yes, actually, there's
a $35 charge I don't recognize.
VIRTUAL AGENT:
From last week, it
looks like it's
an overdraft fee.
PRISHA: Oh, that's not fair.
I didn't know.
VIRTUAL AGENT: OK,
let me transfer you
to a specialist to help.
ROGER MARTINEZ: More
complex cases are seamlessly
handed off to a human agent.
[RINGTONE]
ELLIOTT: Hi,
Prisha, I'm Elliott.
I see you're concerned
about the overdraft fee.
PRISHA: Yeah, I didn't
know I would get charged.
ELLIOTT: OK, I can
waive the fee this time,
but would you like
overdraft protection,
so it doesn't happen again?
ROGER MARTINEZ: Agent
Assist listens in,
giving real time,
step by step guidance.
PRISHA: Yes, please.
ELLIOTT: OK, I've set it up.
Is there anything else?
PRISHA: No, this was great.
Thanks a lot.
ROGER MARTINEZ: Lastly, Insights
gives you real time visibility
into key called
drivers and sentiment.
But there are so
many more places
CCAI can be leveraged
in financial services.
For example, it can
streamline the user's ability
to manage their account
information, like password
resets.
Or it can help facilitate
the user paying their bills,
activating or
deactivating credit cards,
or other types of transactions.
CCAI can help with
bigger scope tasks,
like helping customers generate
and understand their credit
scores, and view or redeem
rewards for their memberships
based upon transactions.
With lots of features
like sentiment analysis,
multilingual support, automatic
topic determination, and chat
level analytics, CCAI
provides a versatile tool
to handle a number of solutions
to improve your customer's
experience with your company.
If you'd like to know
more, visit the link
in the description below.
You can also subscribe
to our Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Contact Center AI content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]